all right welcome back everyone to
episode number lucky number 13 of the
beginner to master for speedrun coming
into today ra
944 I'm currently on a 44 game win
streak can switch to my profile here uh
I do have a new profile picture and we
are approaching interesting territory uh
I'll hopefully be able to keep the win
streak going uh one interesting thing
I've noticed is I have not played a
single opponent rated above 1,000 ELO so
maybe that will change today but let's
waste no more time and let's hop into
the first
game okay playing Milo
202 more numbers Etc okay we have E4
play
E5 and not sure how many games I'll play
this episode but uh okay getting very
used to this opening I'll play Knight C
6 defending the pawn in E5 I've
encountered this a decent amount over
the course of the
series um this has to be at least like
the fifth or sixth game opponent
obviously wants to Checkmate me so I
will play
G6 uh I think I've explained this
position many times uh really you just
want to defend against the opponent's
threats this case white still wants to
Checkmate me so I'll instruct the queen
and develop the
Knight and pawn
C3 so I'm pretty sure I have this
position maybe had something
similar um Pawn C3 it's a useful move
preventing Knight to
D4 and now it's a question how I want to
proceed with development like usually in
King's Pawn openings the bishop likes to
go to
C5 uh but with Pawn C3 if I play Bishop
C5 like white might expand with B4 and
B5 and because I've already committed to
G6 I think I'm just happier playing
Bishop
G7 and yeah just getting ready to Castle
hopefully having a a solid King side and
the plan going forward from here is to
complete development with this bishop uh
very possibly get the bishop to G4 maybe
try and exploit the the queen Knight H3
is interesting uh Knight H3 does put the
Knight on the rim but it does have the
idea of playing Knight G5 and tting the
F
Pawn I'll just Castle here with castling
I ensure that there's not going to be
any issues with
F7 okay we see Pawn
D3 so maybe White's preparing Bishop
G5 uh but only one one of the minor
pieces for white can access G5 at a time
so I if if I really want to like stop
white from developing further I could
play
H6 but I think that's a little bit
slow I me I think it's uh it's a
question between H6 or
D6 if I play D6 I do allow Bishop
G5 but it's not the worst thing ever
like maybe then I can play
H6 kick the bishop and then try and a
little
bit I'll play Pawn
D6 also my opponent is rated just below
a thousand so I guess if they if they
beat me this game they'll get their
rating goal um if they lose to me then
their their rating will be
refunded uh as is the case with all my
opponents in this
series so Knight
G5 I mean honestly when I saw Queen H5
on move two I thought this this is going
to be like a pretty easy game but um
yeah white hasn't made any like serious
blunders with Knight G5 that signals
that maybe White's going for Knight
takes
F7 and I'm going to provoke white
to to move in the
Knight and if we see Knight takes F7
then generally that's like a very good
trade for black I'll get two minor
pieces for rook and Pawn uh but then
going into the middle game the minor
pieces will be much more useful than
rook and pawn so opponent uh realizes
that Knight takes F7 was not preferable
Knight H3 was probably the best move
there now Whit's essentially wasted a
couple Tempe moving the Knight back and
forth and now I can probably continue
now I don't want to take the Knight
because Knight's just a very bad piece
for white I think I'm happy to play
Bishop to G4 developing with a back on
the
queen uh but the question is what to do
next F3 might be
coming I should note here that like
imagine white plays F3 and I Retreat
then G6 is actually a weak point in my
position because my F Pawn is pinned
there is potential for Queen JS G6 later
if I'm not
careful so have to be a little bit uh
yeah awake here to avoid
blendering Knight A5 comes to mind
but do I want to play Knight
A5 does attack the
bishop D5 also comes to mind but then D5
um would make the Knight overworked it's
already defending the
bishop so yeah what to do could play
Queen
D7 and F3 and then maybe I can take or
move move
back I think Queen D7 is pretty
solid and it connects the Rooks too
which is a sign that I'm basically done
with my opening and okay the Queen's a
little bit more
useful okay we see Knight G1 so white
moving a lot with the
Knight and
now and one of the benefits with Queen
D7 is I over defended the bishop so my
Knight's no longer tied down I can play
the move Knight H5 to attack the queen
then the queen has E3 so I'm not quite
trapping the
queen yeah maybe I don't want
to move this Knight so
soon and D5 is another consideration but
after takes takes then the queen is
overworked and then takes takes and
takes so what to
do I want to punish white I think maybe
now is the time for Knight A5
we're trying to
remove one of White's only developed
pieces okay so white
counterattacks my Bishop it's actually
not a bad move so I take here white
takes here and then the H file opens I
don't really want to go into
that so Bishop E6 I
guess struggling to get like a a very
clear Advantage I mean one of the goals
is to try and open the center given
white has most of the things
undeveloped I think it's very likely
will trade off the
Bishops after he takes I don't want to
take with Pawn because Queen takes G6 I
can take with
Queen have to manage my time
here ooh okay white going full
aggressive
mode um but I think this is the first
like very big mistake for white cuz once
I take the
bishop and assuming the pawn recaptures
I'll take on
e4 and the queen will be attacked the
pawn will still be
attacked now we see White's
position beginning to
crumble I think it's kind of an
important lesson that we see from this
game is sometimes it's not easy to
immediately punish the opponent
for
making making Stakes or violating
opening principles like sometimes the
best approach is just to be solid be
patient follow principles
yourself keep the pressure here I save
the Knight attack The
Rook Rook H3 I'll very happily play Pawn
F4 unleashing the
attack yeah super solid position I've
not lost uh a single Pawn we see Rook
H2 and ideally I I just want to open the
the position and get to White's King I
mean E4 comes to mind E4 takes I can't
take back with Pawn because the Knight
hangs kind of like the idea of starting
with this
move reinforcing the king's side also
creating the battery so attacking the C
pong and yeah I'll I'll have to start
playing much more quickly here already
below four minutes it's always a
tradeoff with uh these games like I'm
trying to explain every move I make try
and provide some lessons but sometimes
that comes with using a bit more time
than I normally
would so here white can defend with uh
some moves or not
defend Knight E2 attacks the Knight but
I'm going to take and Counterattack the
queen also skewering the queen and the
Knight now we see some nice
geometry white will be losing some
material here
and assuming the queen Retreats
somewhere I think I'll take on E2 with
my
knight and then hit the bishop on
C1 yeah it's a nice kind of chain of
Defense Queen defends a bishop defends a
knight guaranteed to take if I want to
uh but I can also take
here yeah I think there's more reason to
take here I know like usually when
you're up material a good strategy is to
trade and simplify but another strategy
is to attack in this case the Knight is
a much better attacker than this bishop
is doing
anything have a nice uh nice Pawn chain
outpost on
G3 if I want to be fancy I could play
Bishop
F1 but yeah let's be let's be civilized
Bishop E6 attacking The
Rook
opponent maybe trying
to to play against my clock
time up a lot of material
now 11 points of material according to
chess.com
if the opponent doesn't resign I think
E4 is very likely to come next to
unleash the
bishop also to try and open the E file
get a rook
involved um do I want to trade
Queens might as
well sometimes when you're attacking you
want to keep Queens on the board to more
efficiently checkmates but in this
case um yeah it simplifies and I'm still
going to have a lot of pieces to
checkmate
with maybe White's trying to sacrifice
everything and hope for
stalemate which at this level like it's
usually a reason to not resign like ever
because there's always uh the off chance
an opponent will get
overconfident but yeah still mate was
not happening so okay nice uh nice game
overall I mean opponent went for the
four move Checkmate I didn't get
checkmated I follow opening principles
developed got my king safe white lost a
lot of time going for this attack which
didn't really work ended up retreating
and I mean it did take time to actually
win material H3 I think was a good
move and in this moment this was the
biggest mistake white could have taken
and I mean this is still playable where
white can still try and develop and have
a a reasonable position but uh I would
have been looking to play D5 and open
the center and just keep the pressure
on so so let's move on was the first
game so 45 games streak see how long I
can keep it going for playing AP red fox
let's play
E4 we have the Sicilian I think I'll
play um a similar opening to what I
played in episode
12 where my opponent also played Knight
C6 and rather than going for open
Sicilian uh the move I sometimes like to
play here is Pawn C3 it's called the
delayed alipin and the idea is to Simply
play D4 take over the
center um the two main moves for black
are to attack the pawn either with
Knight F6 or
D5 um but a lot of players at this level
don't play those moves and usually allow
white to take over the
center so we'll see how my opponent
reacts Pawn D6 I'm very happy to get the
two Pawns in the
center usually the point of the Sicilian
is to trade a c Pawn or a d Pawn uh but
in this case I've converted my C Pawn
into a d Pawn so I keep my two Center
pawns and um now I control a bit more
space and this is one of the goals with
a lot of openings and chests is just to
control the center squares with the
pawns and then have very fluid develop
with the knights and
Bishops I think depending what black
does that will determine how I complete
development and it's very likely that I
want to Castle as quickly as
possible but we see D5 okay so have to
react to this
move um there's a few options here I
could take I could push or I could
develop and defend
and honestly like all of the options
look very reasonable there's definitely
an argument to go
for like any of these but I think the
move I like the best is
taking cuz once the queen takes back
then I can develop with
attack and I can keep attacking I'm
going to play this move
D5 which gains more space hits the
Knight if Knight moves there might be
some Bishop B5
coming Knight doesn't have a great
square if Knight B4 I have Queen A4
check to win the
Knight otherwise like these squares are
a bit ugly these squares were off limits
um cuz my KN on
F3 so life is pretty good I mean we're
eight Moves In Black has not developed a
single thing like every single black
thing is on its starting
square but it's still a question like
how to maximize my advantage from this
position if I play Bishop B5 then like
black will block with Bishop D7 or
Knight
D7 probably Bishop D7 and offer the
trade it's not easy to attack
anything like directly or like even
generate any tactics
because black has everything uh on its
starting Square so I think I'll start
with Bishop B5 which does directly
attack the king and if Bishop
D7 I think I'll just Castle here leave
the tension between the Bishops if takes
I don't mind my knight coming in then
maybe there's potential for Bishop F4
and um and Knight
C7 yeah actually Bishop F4 looks nice
just completing
development leaving the tension between
the Bishops
black trying to relieve the
tension so now I have to choose like do
I trade do I
Retreat do I Retreat the other
way I'm dreaming of some like Rook E1
and then Knight D6 Checkmate that would
be a funny smother mate uh can't quite
achieve it so easily from this
position I mean the general rule here is
when you have more space
case you should avoid trading minor
pieces so I'm just going to move
back it does allow B5 but then I'll move
back and keeping all the minor pieces on
the board for
now and usually the reason why like
white should avoid trades in this
position is because black is a little
bit more cramped like the bishop is
taking away the square for the
Knight um we might see Bishop G4
probably one of the better moves
but then like if black takes and I can
activate the queen and yeah life is
still very very
good so Queen C8 attacking the
bishop debating between Queen E2 or
Bishop
B3 I think both of these moves are fine
we're going to play Bishop B3 one plan
is now that the queen is on this open
file it's the only file on the board
with no pawns on it I have a very simple
plan of Rook
C1 and now that my Bishop is no longer
in the way of the C file a rook C1 would
already thren some Knight B5 ideas to
discover the attack and then Fork on C7
so let's play Rook
C1 setting up I think this is setting up
like the first tactical threat of the
game not so easy for black to stop like
the kn Knight can't can't come to
C6 the best move might be Queen d8 which
is kind of a sad
move and if Queen d8 then I'll have to
try and figure out how to keep making
progress because it is hard to access
C7 if I if I don't have the discovered
attack
well I might end up doing like if Queen
d8 I could just play Rook E1 and keep
optimizing like the whole
position it's one of the few pieces not
doing anything is this work on
F1 it is pretty rare that uh have a game
where I'm up on time after the opening I
usually I take more time explaining
things but yeah Lock's in a difficult
spot
here
and queen C5 is another attempt which
does stop Knight B5 but it would allow
some other
discoveries and there's also Bishop G7
I'm wondering maybe black can play this
I play Knight B5 and then take the rook
and take the Knight give away the queen
but get some material for
it and it spots like this which
definitely diffult to play
but like not all hope is is totally lost
for
black opponent taking a very long time I
might uh cut out the long think in
editing feel like I've explained most
things going on in this
position um but in general it's it's
good to think on your opponent's time a
lot of players maybe have the habit of
playing a move and then just turning off
their brain or letting their mind wander
but if you can try and anticipate what
the opponent might do or try and
identify the the ideas or just um like
key key features of the position it's a
useful way of um just thinking on your
Pawn's
time I'm imagining Rook E1 and pawn
D6 okay well opponent resigns so maybe a
a slightly
anticlimactic
finish but uh yeah it was a very food
opening I
mean I think we see
the the the Venom of this this early C3
move followed by
D4 um black played what a lot of players
would do kind of trying to to play
naturally um but D5 I think was um a
clear mistake in the opening cuz it
moved the same Pawn twice even though
black was trying to fight for the center
it just gave me time to attack things
and gain space and develop and then life
was very
good so uh rated
962 let's keep moving
on okay playing big Trump
fan uh this is my first opponent rated
above a
thousand so maybe the biggest challenge
incoming are we going to see
another
uh another Scholars mate no we see a
Vienna Vienna is an acceptable
opening I'm a little bit disappointed we
were're not seeing a
chowski a Vienna Gambit I know um no
Levy used to cover this opening a lot I
there's a lot of content creators that
like to make videos about this or
recommend this um against
F4 it's actually a difficult move to
deal with if you haven't studied it
before because if I take then like
already E5 or Knight
F3 and white can very often grab the
center early on so the best move here is
Pawn to
D5 which creates a a bit of Chaos in the
center but I am counterattacking the
pawn on e4 so after it takes it's a fair
trait and because white moved the F Pawn
uh there are some cases where Queen H4
check can be considered in this case
Queen H4 just runs into
G3 and queen F3 I think is a move that
Levy like to recommend maybe he has a
course on
it and a few years ago I played a match
against him Where I Was preparing this
opening in depth and uh there's two
moves here there's Knight C6 or F5 and
um having studied both of the moves I I
prefer
F5 even though it looks risky I do open
this diagonal uh Queen H5 I just have
G6 and if on pant then I can simply
recapture with Knight and then have easy
development Castle
quickly meanwhile I do reinforce the
Knight on
e4 and yeah usually the the best move is
to play D3 to kick my knight I'm going
to take
on
C3 and coming up there's a very
important move we're still following
opening
Theory um but for anyone that maybe
plays this line as black it's important
to not just like memorize the moves but
also understand the moves so in this
position if it's white to move white
would play D4 and have like a really
really good structure really good game
going into the middle game so in order
to stop D4 I can play D4
myself and what this does is it in some
cases creat creates a situation where
the pawn will have less Defenders uh
just because Pawn D4 is no longer
possible for white and I'm ready to play
Knight
C3 uhoh I just lose my camera what just
happened oh
no see if this works I'm going to take
the
pawn there we go okay uh that's never
happened before anyway we have a
position after eight moves of the
opening where for both sides we only
have one developed thing and that's our
our Queens but with Queen digs Z4 I'm
hitting the rook and the
eong oh
no I'm going to have to troubleshoot my
camera I don't know what's happening
let's try this again uh in the
meantime let's keep making
moves uh this is actually a very very
good position now whites
counterattacked but with G6 I counter
Counterattack and now the Queen the pawn
and The
Rook are all attacked in White's
position and after my opponent played
the first seven moves like perfectly at
like Grandmaster level um we see okay we
see some issues with my
camera oh no my camera
battery all right let's take a rook
actually I I should explain this cuz
um it looks like I could take the pawn
with check and then take the Rook but if
I take the pawn with check first then
white can play Queen E2 pinning my queen
to the king and then I won't be able to
legally take the Rook so it's better to
take it right
away I'm hoping the camera will will
survive for the rest of this
game also hoping my opponent will not
survive for much
longer now yeah I do have to be careful
of my queen aligned with White's Queen
like if somehow Bishop C1 to B5 check
was possible then that would win my
queen but uh yeah it's a dark Square
Bishop my King's on a light Square so
not too much concern of
tactics also no concern about the queen
getting trapped cuz um yeah has a lot of
room and I could start with Queen C3 I
could take the a pawn I could play
Bishop to
B4 I like Bishop B4 very simply
developing with
attack I've I've said this phrase a few
times this episode uh it's also known as
developing with Tempo I just bring out a
piece gain time attacking the
opponent and like generally these types
of moves you don't need to think about
too much like it just improves and then
opponent has to figure out how to defend
with Bishop D2 then that will give me
the option of trading everything or
maybe even winning the pawn on
D4 if King F2 then white loses casting
rights so position is looking good
here and there's also King
E2 I think King E2 and King F2
I could probably respond in a similar
manner um I mean again I could take the
pawn but I'm more interested
in getting my pieces
developed I like the idea of of just
playing Knight
C6 another developing with attack Type
move now attacking the pawn on D4 it's
also attacked by the
queen
now what white should probably do here
is Play Bishop B5 develop and pin
preventing me from taking on
D4 but then I can develop break the pin
and then again threaten to to take on
D4 so yeah trying to be efficient with
the the developing
moves with Pawn D5 uh this does attack
the Knight and save the D Pawn but it
does kind of abandon the
ewn um I could deliver the check
first but I think I'm I'm happy to take
on
E5 and i' I'd rather have the king stay
on F2 because there there's potential
for Knight G4 or maybe next Bishop to
C5 white could pin like white could play
Queen
E2 but my Knight's already
defended
with Queen E2 I'd probably respond with
Bishop C5
check so it's looking good
here I'm trying to imagine like ways I
could go wrong and there is one way to
go wrong here like if I play the the
seemingly innocuous King f8 that would
be a terrible blunder because Bishop H6
check and that would just blunder my
queen
so I definitely don't want to allow this
Bishop to check my king so I think C6 is
very fine
move even though it might offer to open
the
defile white can't really make use of
it if I want to here I could throw in
some of these
checks but I think taking back still
looks very
[Music]
fine like Knight defends the pawn
attacks a
bishop a bishop doesn't have too many
great squares Knight also restricts a
bishop it does feel weird though that
like both Kings have a lot of like empty
space around them um like two
unsheltered
kings I think it's going to be White's
King who is more
exploitable now it's a question between
Knight G4 or Bishop
C5 and I could
calculate
but I think I'll rely a little bit more
on intuition here I like Knight G4 cuz
it it allows the queen to come back into
the center and then I leave the bishop
controlling
E1 and there is a line here if King
F1 then I have Bishop H Bishop to
A6 this is almost
Checkmate the king would have no legal
moves white would have to block now the
one thing with this move is I leave the
pawn on C6 undefended
so I just have to make sure that I'm I'm
keeping the attack against the
king white has what one two three four
five six legal moves if we include Queen
J
G4 okay we see the king land on
E2 and now I could play Queen E5 check
or Bishop A6 check I think are the
two main moves to consider Let's Play
Bishop A6
check there's been a lot of moves this
game developing with attack it's another
example okay King to F3 it's like very
close to checkmating I have Queen
C3 now the king can't
Retreat it's probably going to have to
move move
forward and there's also Queen
D3 Bishop E3 would get maid in
one so at this point I'm I'm looking for
the force Checkmate seems
close also realizing there's a
possibility for a castle
Checkmate still casting
potential but I should try and finish
things off efficiently I could play G5
here play Queen E5 King
F3 Queen E4 King
G3 Bishop
E1 that looks good
enough oh there's also King G5 which
would be kind of
funny King G5 it's black to move and
check maen one uh if you want to try and
find it feel free to pause the video I
think there's only one Checkmate in one
here and let's go ahead and play
it Bishop E7
Checkmate so that was a 20 move
game um we saw actually a pretty highle
opening I think that's the first time I
encountered the Vienna Gambit in the
speedrun series and my opponent knew
like the the first several moves like
through
D3 and then once I played d for think
this is this was the first big mistake
is taking the pawn uh I'm pretty sure
white is supposed to play Knight E2 here
is um is it Knight
E2 engine saying Queen
G3 uh Queen G3 preparing Knight
F3 and it actually gets complicated cuz
yeah white basically sacrifices the pawn
on C3 and then can play this move Bishop
E2
and then there is some ideas of Bishop
H5 check or putting the bishop on F3 and
then later Knight
E2 so um yeah usually like at a higher
level if you play the Vienna Gambit you
have to
know past the first few moves of the
opening like past E4 especially if um if
black plays a critical line of course at
this level it won't happen so often that
black will know Theory but um hopefully
some lessons to take away and uh yes
this is useful for anyone who plays E4
E5 as black like if you encounter the
Vienna it's good to know this move Pawn
D5 and then even further this move Pawn
F5 usually offers a nice
game so uh currently rated
972 on my way to getting to th000 Evo I
think I'm going to wrap it up here try
and resolve whatever count issues I was
having uh thankfully it's alive now but
I might have to like switch out the
battery so do stay tuned for the next
episode where hopefully I'll break 1,000
ELO I'll see you guys soon